et la question que j'aurais vous posez
madame la première ministre sait quelles
étaient vos rêves étant jeune fille
oui c'est assez discret non en fait moi
j'étais attiré par les sciences ce qui
est pas forcément évident parce que je
vois c'est ça serait un peu long à
raconter mais je trouve que quand on a
un parcours de vie difficile ce qui est
mon cas et qui peut vous arriver des
événements pas très agréable dans la vie
personnelle les sciences un côté
rassurant et des choses logiques et donc
du coup moi ça m'a ça m'a effectivement
attiré et puis après ça en s'accrochant
j'ai intégré une école sam a été bien
utile parce qu'on était payées pour
faire cette école polytechnique et donc
ça m'a permis de financer des études
[Musique]